[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine foot
ball trap a raté une opportunité dans le
championnat de promotion d'honneur les
trappistes n'ont pu faire mieux que 1
partout sur leur teint dans leur match
en retard au plus tôt plus
d'informations à suivre dans quelques
instants automobile ce sera une grande
première en novembre prochain le rallye
des gazelles arrêt d'ordinaire 100%
féminin créé en 1990 va s'ouvrir aux
hommes dans les yvelines un duo
originaire de vélizy-villacoublay va
participer à cette compétition
leurs portraits dans ce magazine course
à pied sidy diallo 61 ans réalisait 151
marathon et ultramar attention 55 pays
et sept continents en tout juste six ans
et demi une performance qui réalise
pieds nus nous lui avons posée à trois
questions
les principaux résultats du week-end
dans le département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football dans le championnat de
promotion d'honneur l'équipe seniors de
l'étoile sportive de trappes n'a pas
réussi à s'imposer sur son terrain
contre plus tôt ce dimanche les deux
équipes sont reparties dos à dos 1 but
partout
une contre performance qui pourrait
avoir des conséquences sur la suite du
championnat
nicolas landry pour les images
coup d'arrêt pour trappe dans la course
à la montée les bleus ciel ont manqué
l'occasion de se rapprocher des leaders
de promotion nord après leur match nul à
domicile contre le 12e plus tôt pourtant
tout avait bien commencé pour les
trappistes avec ce but dès la 25e minute
de jeu mais leurs adversaires ont réagi
juste avant la mi-temps sur coup franc
en seconde période le score n'évoluera
plus un but partout
la logique un match équilibré où chaque
chaque équipe a eu sept enfants atelier
mais moi je sais fermé où chaque équipe
avait des anges est un peu différent
donc tout ne va pas rater des points
c'est un match assez fermé où tous les
contacts un peu après vous pas un peu
dur à voir donc ça reste acquis pour moi
logique encore une fois on a eu du mal
contre les équipes du bas de tableau
quand on joue contre les les gros cadors
du championnat en général on arrive à à
prendre les quatre points
c'est dommage parce qu'on a ouvert le
score et encore une fois on prend un but
sur coup de pied arrêté et du coup ça
nous ralentit un petit peu sur la course
à la montée
malgré cette contre-performance les bons
points de cet après midi sont une
nouvelle fois distribué du côté de la
défense
une vraie force cette saison avec
seulement 17 buts encaissés depuis le
début du championnat les trappistes sont
toujours la défense la plus hermétique
de cette poule et l'ont prouvé ce
dimanche c'est un match assez compliqué
donc encore fait preuve de solidarité
on a on s'accrochait ce que c'est quand
même un chien assez dur quand même
malgré l'enjeu on a su on a su faire
face à la sarre de puteaux qu'avait
aussi un match ça va faire au classement
tra pro prend la troisième place avec
encore un match en retard à jouer la
montée est toujours envisageable
il nous reste trois matches à la maison
trois matchs à l'extérieur donc c'est
équitable
on va on va faire ce qu'il faut pour
monter on a largement les capacités
il reste six matches quatre points à
prendre part aux matchs donc 24 points à
prendre et normalement on devrait pas
être très loin de la montée trappe se
rendra sur le terrain de torcy ce
dimanche 16 avril une victoire pour leur
permettre de revenir à trois points du
leader boulogne billancourt
on reste dans le milieu du football on
prend la direction de
vélizy-villacoublay le club local et la
chance d'accueillir au stade robert
wagner pour la première fois un stage
organisé par la fondation du real de
madrid 11 fois vainqueur de la ligue des
champions
quatre-vingt-dix enfants âgés de 7 à 14
ans se sont fait coacher pendant cinq
jours par des entraîneurs professionnels
ils ont pu également revêtir le célèbre
maillot madrilène à l'issue de ce stage
les trois meilleurs joueurs
participeront à une finale nationale et
pourront peut-être jouer un jour à match
au stade santiago bernabéu
on écoute les réactions moi j'ai survécu
j'ai un seul regret c'est pas avoir
l'âge de pouvoir le faire parce que
franchement quand je vois tout ce qu'ils
ont fait cette semaine c'est
le footballeur c'était vraiment un stage
une semaine exceptionnelle remarqué
qu'il y avait plusieurs joueurs ici avec
de la technique et du talent parmi les
90 enfants présents on a pu voir des
footballeurs avec un très bon niveau
on a notamment les yeux sur quatre
joueurs se la sont sous la coupe des
managers pendant ce stage et pourrait
intégrer la grande finale nationale du
football on passe au handball chez les
fils montigny-le-bretonneux ne s'arrête
plus de gagner les îles lointaines ont
écrasé le club de dreux deuxième du
championnat à l'extérieur 27 à 16 une
cinquième victoire consécutive qui
permet au club de grappiller des places
dans le championnat de national une
avant derniers au mois de novembre
montini se retrouve 5e à 4 points de la
deuxième place et plus encore viser la
montée à la fin de la saison
une remonte à da folle que nous explique
le président du club christophe reding
aujourd'hui l'objectif du club était le
maintien dans les six premières c'est un
objectif qui est atteint mais on
s'interdit rien l'objectif d'une montée
n'est pas irréalisable
mathématiquement c'est possible il va
falloir que certains paramètres entrent
en jeu que les équipes devant nous
perdre et mat sur les six derniers qui
restent et que nous on fait au continue
notre spirale de gagnant on continue par
du football américain les templiers
renoue avec la victoire après quatre
défaites consécutives dans le
championnat de deuxième division les
élans courtois sont allés s'imposer chez
les vikings de villeneuve d'ascq ce
week-end lors de la 8e journée
avec cette victoire 27 à 10 les
templiers sont toujours en vie et
peuvent espérer se qualifier pour les
playoffs de fin de saison
ils sont pour l'instant 3e du
championnat à deux journées de la fin à
notre sport originaire des états unis
étaient à l'honneur ce week-end en
baseball les cougars de montillot bottle
n'ont pas réussi à créer l'exploit sur
le terrain de rouen l'une des meilleures
équipes de france
les il monte un ont été terrassés lors
de cette deuxième journée de première
division le score 8 1 dans le premier
match et 9 à 0 dans le second
les cougars ont à coeur de rectifier le
tir dimanche prochain sur le terrain des
templiers de sénart ce sera une grande
première en novembre prochain le rallye
des gazelles art est d'ordinaire 100%
féminin créé en 1990 va s'ouvrir aux
hommes
la direction de la course propose de
partir entre amis en couple mixte
maroc dans les yvelines un duo
originaire de vélizy-villacoublay va
participer à cette compétition alors
l'anguille pour les images un couple
dans la vie une passion commune le
mythique rallye des gazelles ces deux
habitants de vélizy-villacoublay vont
participer ensemble à la première
édition de ce raid
ouverte aux hommes on a toujours eu
cette envie de partir et partager notre
envie de conduire un 4 4 sur des pistes
on aime les grands espaces on aime le
maroc
un baptême du feu pour pascal burg le
sportif est partie de l'organisation
depuis 15 ans mais n'a jamais pris le
départ de l'épreuve
al'inverse sa femme fabienne lalande est
une gazelle chevronné a déjà participé à
quatre éditions donc le rallye il
approche huile de caunes et il sait ce
que c'est mais je dirais en théorie par
rapport aux participants et alors le
voir de l'extérieur c'est une chose et
le voir de l'intérieur c'est autre chose
et c'est vraiment quelque chose de
fabuleux c'est une très belle aventure
et ça valait le coup qu'on le partage
tous les deux dans le 4 4 les rôles sont
déjà répartis pascal burg laissera le
volant à sa faim plan toute la durée de
l'épreuve pour se concentrer sur
l'orientation interdiction d'utiliser un
gps seuls des cartes en noir et blanc
datant des années 60 et la boussole sont
autorisés ce qui me plaît dans la
navigation c'est toute la partie c'est
tout à fait moi en fait intellectuel
donc la réflexion le choix la stratégie
donc j'en sais ce que je vais travailler
puisque en temps normal suis plutôt au
volant d'un véhicule un des 4 4 mais là
je vais me mettre à côté
je vais essayer de guide et fabienne du
mieux que je puisse donc c'est vraiment
cette partie là khimki matière et c'est
vraiment mon gros de challenge pour être
prêt à 100% le jour j les deux
aventuriers pratique le hors piste
régulièrement dans les forêts de la
région parisienne avec leurs véhicules
une première approche de la compétition
sans les dunes maintenant moi je
travaille mes cartes fabienne de temps
en temps dès qu'on peut on roule roule
au volant du véhicule pour ne rien
perdre et surtout apprivoiser on va dire
le véhicule ce duo encore quelques mois
pour dompter ce 4 4 le gaz et l'ennemi
n'est programmée du 4 au 11 novembre
dans le désert marocain
un mot de golf à présent la ryder cup
2018 l'équivalent de la coupe du monde
de la discipline sera organisé du 28 au
30 septembre au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
si vous voulez assister à cet événement
les pré inscriptions en ligne sont
désormais ouvertes
vous avez jusqu'à septembre pour remplir
un formulaire sur le site officiel de la
compétition
à noter que les licenciés de la
fédération française de golf sont
prioritaires dans les réservations au
total plus de 200 mille personnes
devraient assister à ce rendez vous on
va ouvrir une page course à pied dans ce
magazine à sidy diallo n'a pas participé
au marathon de paris le week-end dernier
mme il a couru sans 51 marathons et
ultra marathons dans 55 pays et sur sept
continents sur six ans et demi
depuis quelques années il a même décidé
de retirer ses chaussures pour courir un
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
la semaine dernière juste avant son
départ pour le marathon de rotterdam
c'est très simple j'avais cinq ans cinq
ans à chicago où j'étais arrivé deux
années plus tôt et pendant deux éditions
du marathon de chicago j'ai applaudi
les couleurs plus de 40000 qui passait
devant chez moi des gens comme moi des
hommes et des femmes et des hommes comme
moi et 40000 personnes qui passent
devant chez vous qui sont en train de
courir 42 km 42 km en 2010 10 octobre
2010 leur marathon de chicago
donc j'ai décidé de d'être parmi les
couleurs et pour que les autres aussi me
voit et qui se disent pourquoi pas
c'est retour à la case départ parce
qu'en fait quand on court le marathon
notre cerveau reptilien il pense qu'on
est en train de chasser pour amener à
manger à bb et à la famille à la tribu
et comme il sait que les individus sont
par définition fainéants les individus
de toutes les espèces ne sont pas une
exception sont fainéants
donc il faut les encourager d'où la
libération des endorphines qui fait que
les gens des villes entre guillemets à
chromé s'est pas accru ses confères
l'amour aussi parce qu'il faut avoir des
enfants pour la survie de l'espèce
c'est le même job le plaisir les gens
vous raconte jean mais pis du marathon
parents mais c'est absurde
nos ancêtres et pratiquer la chasse l
épuisement et c'était des courses de
longue distance de découpe d'endurance
sans savoir quand ça se termine alors
que nous quand on commence une course
sans cesse et 42 km que ces 50 km il
savait pas il fallait attraper l'animal
et si la scop est pas parce qu un autre
prédateur supérieur est venu qu'ils ont
eu peur que l'animal a réussi à les
semer
totalement le lendemain il fallait il
fallait repartir non que nos ancêtres
étaient capables de faire ses courses
tous les jours
les humains sont censés marcher et
courir pieds nus finit bien marcher et
courir pieds nus
non seulement on n'a pas besoin de
chaussures mais les chaussures ne font
que nous causer de problème quand on
court quant au marché et à moins
d'efforts mais à la course ça ne pose
que de problèmes ça vous change la
démarche vous atterrissez sur le talon
le pied droit
cela veut dire que tout l'impact du
liquor va directement au sol
effectivement si vous avez des
chaussures avec l avoir un peu d'amour
qui se ment ça est amorti un peu mais
c'est pas par contre si vous courez
pieds nus l'impact est réduit vous
atterrissez au milieu ou à l'avant des
pieds et toute la mécanique des pieds et
de la jambe effet que l'impact soit
considérablement réduit et en plus dans
ce cas l'impact aussi c'est la partie
c'est tout le pied au lieu que ce soit
uniquement si maintenant on a besoin de
chaussures lorsqu'on a besoin de gars
c'était quand il fait froid on se
protège puisque notre corps n'est pas
fait pour l'hiver français ou européens
[Musique]
du cyclisme au pour débuter cet agent
d'al vélo-club de montillot bretonneau
organise ce dimanche 16 avril de 8h à
12h son grand prix plus de 180 coureurs
et une dizaine de clubs de la région
parisienne s'élanceront pour cette
deuxième édition
ils vont parcourir entre 54 et 75 km à
travers une boucle de 3 km si vous
voulez assister à la compétition le
départ sera donné rue du petit pont à
côté de l'avenue à nicolas à bouffe et
on referme ce journal par du football un
choc est programmée ce week end dans le
championnat de division excellence en
match en retard du en cours saint
quentin septième du championnat reçoit
ce dimanche à 16h l'équipe réserve de
versailles deuxième du classement en cas
de victoire montigny le bretonneux
pourrait s'emparer de la quatrième place
versailles de son côté doit l'emporter
pour devenir le leader du classement
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
fil 78
[Musique]